bitcoiners have long talked about the
largest oil producers in the world
getting on to the bitcoin standard one
of the key elements to that story was
that those oil producers would end up
realizing that bitcoin was the most
profitable use for their energy
production now that is exactly what
we're finding out yesterday exxon mobil
it became official that they have been
mining bitcoin what they are doing is
they are diverting excess natural gas
that usually would go to flaring and
being burnt off into the environment
they instead are sending that over out
of their north dakota facility to their
partner caruso energy where they are
mining bitcoin the largest u.s oil
producer is now mining bitcoin that is a
big big deal they are not the only oil
producer in the united states who's
doing this we found out a few months ago
that canoco phillips was doing the same
now bitcoin mining is preventing
environmental damage this is counter to
the public narrative now that we know
that exxon mobil is diverting that
excess natural gas that would have been
flared to mine bitcoin you have to
support bitcoin mining if you're into
climate change and actually making sure
that the environment is taken care of
what we are watching is a complete
narrative violation bitcoin mining is
good for the environment it prevents all
of those bad things that come from gas
flaring from occurring and so we've got
this quote right here from the exxon
spokeswoman we continuously evaluate
emerging technologies aimed at reducing
flaring volumes across our operations
it's exactly what you would expect from
exxon mobil trying to do the right thing
trying not to flare more and more gas
into the environment they simply want to
mitigate it and if they can make money
along the way that's real interesting to
them oil producers in the united states
and internationally are coming to the
realization exactly what bitcoiners
thought that they would bitcoin is the
single most profitable use of their
energy production and now that the oil
and gas industry is going all in on
bitcoin i tend to think that there's no
putting this genie back in the bottle
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time